ukraine's president says there needs to
be meaningful talks with russia the
warring sides have held several meetings
despite the relentless fighting on the
ground
but do these talks serve any purpose
and can they end the fighting this is
inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim joom civilians under siege
in ukraine's mario paul are experiencing
some of the most relentless fighting
since the war began
russia sees the southern port city as
vital for its military campaign while
keeve accuses moscow of committing war
crimes
but despite the lack of de-escalation a
small group is trying to end the war
through dialogue representatives from
both sides have met several times
there are three main points a ceasefire
an end to all hostilities and
humanitarian corridors but there's been
no progress so far and the attacks are
continuing
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
says the only way to stop the conflict
is through talks
i'm sure you understand that
negotiations are not easy or pleasant
but they are needed
it's about life ukraine's always sought
a peaceful solution moreover we're
interested in peace now because we count
everyone killed for it's important to us
every destroyed family every destroyed
house because we're ukrainians and for
us a person is priceless
moscow says it launched its invasion to
quote demilitarize and denazify ukraine
but insists it's ready to stop fighting
if keeve meets its conditions which
includes ukraine ceasing all its
military action to defend itself
moscow also wants assurances of
so-called neutrality it wants ukraine to
amend its constitution to prevent it
from joining any political or military
bloc in the future
the kremlin also wants ukraine to
acknowledge the crimean peninsula as
russian territory
and it wants kiev to recognize the
separatist regions of donetsk and
lugansk as independent
all right let's introduce our panel in
kiev vladimir kulik head research fellow
at the national academy of sciences of
ukraine
in berlin ulrich bruckner professor of
political science at stanford university
in berlin
and in moscow pavel felgenhauer a
defense and military analyst a warm
welcome to you all and thank you so much
for joining us on inside story today
vladimir let me start with you today
from your vantage point are there
well is there actually any point to the
talks that have been going on between
ukraine and russia of late
uh
a point is
to find ways to stop bloodshed to stop
murders of ukrainian populations that
russia is uh pursuing so far so
uh
the only
tangible result of this
talk so far has been uh humanitarian
corridors so i i read the reports that
every day
uh hundreds or sometimes thousands of
people are led to safety and from cities
like like mariupole or
eve or suburbs of cave where they they
they were held in in in shell and in in
cellars under the sharing so they they
they were without food without water
without safety so
that's good anything else is uh kind of
debitable maybe russia is just winning
the time to to to bring more
more weapons and and more troops uh
maybe ukraine uh wins time to to bring
uh more weapons from the west so
everything is possible how sincere the
parties are about
wanting to reach a result uh i i i
cannot say vladimir do you think that
from from your perspective do you think
that russia is sincere in trying to find
a peaceful solution right now
uh i doubt it first i doubt anything
russia russia meaning russian leadership
is doing uh they keep saying different
things about their demands uh even
at some point when
even if it seems at some point that the
list of their demands becomes shorter
and more reasonable then the next
statement brings back the long and
absurd list of demands which
which really uh
are not acceptable and cannot be
acceptable at any point for ukraine
for ukrainians so it seems like um
they're not serious about making uh
their demands uh potentially acceptable
so to give uh ukrainians a serious
signal that
they want to compromise
they want a deal uh
maybe they they they are just winning
the time or maybe they are uh
pressure in ukraine behind the scenes so
maybe all their public statements are
just smokescreen i don't know pavel let
me ask you the same question do you
believe that these talks in the format
that they have taken place thus far can
actually yield a result that they might
actually end the fighting bring about
some type of meaningful ceasefire
well it's good of course to have talks
that not to have talks
but the positions of the two sides are
miles apart that's so obvious and
actually on the technical side uh i
don't really like the composition at
least of the russian delegation it
doesn't really indicate
that russia really means that much real
business it's not very optimistic
forecast because the leader of the
delegation mr madinsky is not from
putin's inner circle he doesn't have he
has zero diplomatic experience
not even a politician a former culture
minister before that a
popular nationalistic self-staff
historian if russia wanted to do
something really uh achieving a hard
kind of uh negotiated but compromise a
person like
mitri kozak with lots of experience in
diplomacy and very much well knowing the
ukrainian situation would have been
leading the team and not mr madinski who
of course could translate uh the
ukrainian position to the kremlin and
back the kremlin position to the
ukrainians but doesn't have the power
the capability to negotiate anything on
his own
and the the general staffs of the both
sides are not really represented at the
table and this is very much a military
situation if we want a ceasefire i mean
it's a complicated military situation
just declaring a ceasefire won't bring a
stop to the fighting in the present
position so i'm not optimistic that
there will be as soon any kind of
breakthrough in the talks
ulrich you've heard now what uh both
pavel and vladimir have had to say um
what do you think do you think that real
substantial meaningful change can be
brought about by these talks um
or do you believe as some analysts do
that this is just a way for president
putin perhaps to buy time and what do
you think about the sincerity of both
sides when it comes to these talks
well i don't think that we can compare
the sincerity of both sides because what
we see is an aggressor that invaded a
country without a provocation from the
ukrainian side and announcing very
extreme positions what he announced as
the objectives of this
military operation which is nothing less
than an invasion so it's really like a
rapist
and a victim sit down and
negotiate the terms of what will happen
next it's certainly not a situation that
can be fixed by
a military solution
and so i also agree as the other two
guests said already
that it's very unlikely that
we will see anything that is a
breakthrough
or a reliable result of negotiations
anytime soon
pavel is russia's military strategy
shifting right now and if so how is it
shifting
uh well it's clear that the blitzkrieg
didn't work out though officially
president putin is saying that
everything's on track everything's on
plan it doesn't seem to be so uh but
russia still has the upper hand in terms
of heavy weaponry in terms of long range
missiles of different sorts russia can
hit any target in any part of ukraine
and ukraine cannot hit back against the
centers of military preparations and in
defense industry in russia so russia has
that advantage it has the initiative
more or less still
and is pushing along but the problem of
course is
that it's spring has come and that means
the russian forces will be uh totally
limited to roads uh spreading out into
the countryside especially in the
northern parts of the front uh where
there's sheridan asian as it's known in
russian and ukrainian well that doesn't
work tanks get
stuck down at that mud
so that means it's going to be rather
static more warfare like the siege of uh
mariupol maybe some other cities until
maybe a month's time will go at least
before it begins to dry up especially in
the north and then the fighting mosquito
will pick up the ukrainians are
mobilizing moving uh getting more
soldiers to the front line and getting
weapons from the west
russia most likely also could begin some
kind of form of mobilization as it is
becoming clear that this will be a
dragged out campaign so right now i
believe it's going to be very static
sieges uh small movements and body
movements not at the time for uh
warm kind of deep operations uh kind of
armored columns moving around you can't
do that before it dries up
pavel you know there are some analysts
who are now positing that the conflict
has become a stalemate would you agree
with that assessment
well it's not yet real as tell me russia
has the initiative when they say in
ukraine russia has already lost well now
it did work uh but the
blitzkrieg didn't work that's also clear
they'll have to come up with something
i'm not sure that really that is fully
thought through or understood uh
increasingly number of people here say
if in the present situation russia
should begin to mobilize
a co-op i don't know maybe a million
reservists you have to train them
because they're totally untrained i mean
at least uh several months of basic
training before you can begin
bringing more manpower to the front
because it's it's a
long drawn-out campaign russia will need
or at least a million soldiers to occupy
and control large parts of ukraine that
didn't do that yet ukraine is more the
territory russia controls is ukraine is
minuscule compared to the country and
russia will continue long-range attacks
closer to the borders of poland than
romania and
slovakia and hungary to try to hit
ukrainian the defense industry military
bases the supply lines of weapons and
emissions coming in from the west and
besiege uh mariupol and maybe after its
falls uh which i don't know when it's
going to happen surely
they'll try to move further on to the
kawaii
and to the transistor republic volodymir
moscow's conditions include ukraine
declaring itself neutral ukraine
acknowledging the crimea peninsula as
russian territory and key of recognizing
the separatist regions of donetsk and
lugansk as independent
would ukraine agree to those conditions
uh you forgot
one
more important uh demand namely the
so-called demilitarization uh keeping uh
the general capacity defense capacity
military capacity of ukraine low
and and and
makes the combination of neutrality and
demilitarization um uh highly
problematic and that's highly unlikely
for ukrainians to accept uh in ukrainian
society there is a prevalent predominant
belief actually that not none of this
condition
can be accepted but
the the degree of acceptability is
different so
there is a
sizable minority something like a third
of of respondents in recent surveys
accepting that ukraine might renounce
its nato ambition uh but uh
for for uh recognition of crimea and and
these uh the bats puppet republic um
the percentage something like 10 10
percent so
over the majority of of the population
rejects this these demands but
in terms of nato membership this could
potentially be acceptable even if
problematic and and and then very
difficult to to to to implement actually
because it's a constitutional norm it
requires two thirds of the parliament
votes and and and and then
a reconfiguration of public opinion so
it's it's it's very difficult but
potentially and could be acceptable at
some point if it is decoupled decoupled
from the demand of the militarization so
the logic is like this is a ukraine uh
is a nato member and can have a
limited army but beyond the nato
umbrella or ukraine it doesn't have any
uh uh nato or other military alliance
umbrella and needs to have its own
strong and and uh
capable army so
bose
are definitely
a non-starter uh ulrich if if one is
talking about the possibility of ukraine
declaring itself neutral or
demilitarizing or or pledging not to try
to join nato going forward one would
assume that ukraine in return would need
some guarantees of its security and if
that were the case who potentially would
act as guarantors for ukraine's security
going forward
exactly this is one of the big question
marks and it leads us back to the time
when ukraine became a sovereign state
and accepted the conditions of being
an
a sovereign state by giving up its
nuclear arsenal by receiving the
security guarantees from western forces
which didn't lead to anything because
now in this situation with the invasion
the west was very clear from the start
that nato will not fight
on ukrainian territory so i personally
don't see what kind of neutrality status
practically changes anything that was
the situation before
nato didn't invite ukraine to become a
member it wasn't on the agenda
and i don't see this as a territorial
conflict putin was very clear that what
he actually wants is to restore the
dignity and pride of the soviet union
and wants to rewrite history and wants
nato to move back to the borders of 89
which means that ukraine is only the
beginning
and if he
loses the military operation or the
invasion in ukraine
then we don't know what the limits are
because if he's cornered he doesn't have
anything to lose and then he can cross
thread lines and make use of his
destructive arsenal that goes beyond
imagination
pavel if a negotiated settlement between
ukraine and russia could actually be
reached would president putin
be willing to agree to allow president
zielinski to stay in power or would
president putin want to see president
zielinski out of power
model if he wants him out of power none
[Music]
in any ways but he doesn't like him
that's rather clear and we want to see
someone else in the presidential
position and ukraine of course the
ukrainian president actually doesn't
have that much power under the ukrainian
uh constitution it's more
parliamentary republic than the
presidential one so that's not really
the the real issue apparently here
it's uh really what uh the objectives of
the this operation are and can't put in
except that his
uh gamble didn't work out and try to cut
the losses
or double down
i think he's going to double dandruff
that's what everyone says but of course
you never know
maybe he'll decide to cut losses and
retreat what happened in
georgia when we could have gone to
belishi but didn't and we kind of
settled for
some kind of compromise of sorts so i
don't know for sure i can't guess uh but
right now i believe it's going to
continue maybe even this war may drag
onto the fall
that's also possible
so this this right now seems to be
turning into a war of attrition but
actually russia cannot win a war of
attrition against the united west where
ukraine is just a proxy fighting on the
battlefield but the entire west and its
entire defense industry is working to
arm them with most modern weapons uh
well russia has to ruin its defense
industry which is today not like in the
time of the soviet union the cold war
it's not actually able to produce
mass-produced weapons or munitions that
are right now being spent at the high
level in the high end well medium at
least intensity conflict so it's a
problem it can drag on to the fall but
then there's going to be a very serious
crisis on the russian side they'll have
to do something
to either
end it
in some kind of way i don't know how
that's going to play out vlodimir based
on how things are going thus far i'm
talking about
how things are going in the conflict and
also how things are going at the
negotiating table do you think that
there is a potential for direct talks
between president zielinski and
president putin at some point
i
frankly don't see much of a point in
personal talks it's um um mostly a
symbolic issue uh zelinski uh based on
his previous uh preference for direct
contact still wants to talk to putin uh
putin seems to be reluctant but at some
point he signaled that um for for the
final deal him he might be willing to
meet zelinski uh i see nothing uh that
cannot be delivered through
intermediates through through the
delegation so
um
putin definitely
would love to to to preside over a
military parade
of the victory of russia in cave or or
mario or wherever but that's not gonna
happen so for for
talks which give russia less than uh
what it wanted uh he might not to be
willing to be personally involved uh so
i don't know uh
there are some some some talks about
potential uh meeting in in in turkey uh
it depends on on
whether the parties actually make a deal
uh
zavinsky would definitely want a
personal meeting to to seal the deal uh
whether putin wants that or not uh
depends on on how much he can he he can
get he right now it seems like he's
still unwilling to accept the fact that
he he cannot get what he really wanted
maybe he he still believes that he can
muster uh additional
uh troops and additional weapons and and
and he can still uh get the whole
package that's not gonna happen and i
wanna comment on on pavel's statement
that
ukraine uh is or will just be a proxy in
in in the west's uh war on on on russia
or against russia uh that's that's not
true ukraine is far from from a proxy
ukraine is actually the vital part of of
the war even if except they accept that
the west is actually against russia in
in that war which is which is not really
true now it's russia versus ukraine and
ukraine is is fighting not only
heroically but capably and the west of
course um supplies weapons but the west
keeps its distance doesn't want to to to
incur any losses and actually get
directly involved in so ukraine
demonstrate that it's it's a vital part
it's a crucial part that of that
defense line of against russian
aggression uh ulric um i saw you nodding
along somewhat vlodimir was saying it
looked like you wanted to jump in i'll
let you do that but i also wanted to ask
you
if you think there are any international
actors out there who might be able to
offer a credible diplomatic off-ramp to
president putin
well then the answer is clearly china
because no one else has as much leverage
as china has
after 2014 russia had no other choice
than turning its face towards the east
and becoming very dependent on china and
if china can't afford rising energy
prices
and doesn't want to take the risk of a
global recession as an unintended side
effect of the massive western sanctions
which also means that time is not on the
side of russia when we look at the
bigger picture militarily maybe it is
but
economically speaking and financially
speaking it certainly isn't and the
other side effects are
that the west is united the west is
cutting off its energy dependency from
russia we are seeking frantically
for other
suppliers of energy and change into
renewable energy economy which destroys
the russian economic model there are so
many counter effects of this
intervention
and in the end it's all in beijing's
hand if it takes long or shorter but
beijing hasn't decided yet
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests fella de merculic ulrich
brickner and pablo felgenhauer
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website al jazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim jim the whole team here bye
for now
[Music]
you